two monuments that I would recommend
above all others to those lost in the
Holocaust the Berlin Memorial basically
these Stone and they start off very
shallow you could have a picnic on and
the height just gets higher and higher
and higher and it's mind-numbing and you
lose all perspective as to where you are
and you start to realize what happens
when life is devalued and degraded and
all you see is the coldest deer Stone it
reminds me of Bohemian rhaps it made
sense to Freddie Mercury to write this
thing but if you describe it makes no
sense the next one is Bobby Yar the
sickness of standing near this ditch
where people were just machine gunned
and executed it's a visceral thing that
will cause you to lose your